die grundrente soll kommen die
bundesregierung hat sich nach
monatelangem streit geeinigt aber was
bedeutet das jetzt eigentlich für die
rentner und auch für die jüngere
generation
darüber sprechen wir heute mit kevin
köhler den bundesvorsitzenden der jusos
und wenn ihr fragen an ihn habt könnt
ihr die wie immer hier unten in die
kommentarspalte posten und wir schauen
jetzt erstmal was da genau zur
grundrente beschlossen wurde und wer
eigentlich davon profitiert
jahrzehntelang arbeiten und dann
trotzdem nicht von der rente leben
können so wird es vielen
geringverdienern die grundrente soll das
ändern
sie soll jeder automatisch bekommen der
weniger als 80 prozent der
durchschnittsrente erhält aber
mindestens 35 jahre in die rentenkasse
eingezahlt hat auch teilzeitarbeit
kindererziehung und pflege von
angehörigen werden angerechnet
von der grundrente könnten bis zu 1 5
millionen menschen profitieren
die deutliche mehrheit davon frauen die
grundrente soll ihnen einen monatlichen
zuschlag bescheren
abhängig davon wie lange und wie viel
jemand eingezahlt hat eine friseurin die
40 jahre für 40 prozent des
durchschnittslohns gearbeitet hat könnte
so von 529 auf 934 euro rente kommen
eine bedürftigkeitsprüfung soll es nicht
geben
das vermögen von leuten mit geringer
rente wird nicht berücksichtigt
stattdessen soll aber das einkommen
automatisch geprüft werden
wer unter 1250 euro bleibt mit
bisherigen rentenzahlungen und einkommen
zum beispiel durch mieteinnahmen hat
vollen anspruch auf grundrente wer
darüber liegt dem wird etwas von der
grundrente abgezogen
auch der partner wird einbezogen wenn
paare gemeinsam bei der berechnung über
1950 euro monatlich kommen gibt es
weniger grundrente oder keiner kommen
soll sie ab 2021 kosten circa eine bis
anderthalb milliarden euro im jahr
steuer finanziert und live zugeschaltet
ist mir jetzt der bundesvorsitzende der
jusos kevin kühnert guten abend herr
knapp schönen guten abend aus berlin
schöneberg
herr kühne hat ist das jetzt heute ein
guter tag für alle rentner
das wäre jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
übertrieben dass es gleich für alle
renten ein guter tag ist aber sie haben
es ja eben selbst im beitrag gezeigt für
gut anderthalb millionen rentnerinnen
und rentner ist das eine gute nachricht
weil das sind diejenigen die haben
bereits gearbeitet die haben 35 oder
mehr jahre hinter sich gebracht kinder
erzogen angehörige gepflegt oder sind
eben jeden tag zur arbeit gegangen und
müssen trotzdem heute sozialhilfe vom
amt im alter bekommen und für die löst
sich diese respektlosigkeit anfang 2021
aus aber wir haben damit nicht alle
probleme der altersarmut in deutschland
gelöst wird das behauptet der lügt dann
doch streitpunkt war ja vor allem die
bedürftigkeitsprüfung die wurde jetzt
quasi ersetzt durch eine
einkommensprüfung
halten sie das für nen guten kompromiss
ja ein guter kompromiss ist ja immer
einer bei dem beide seiten
zugeständnisse machen aber es am ende
für die betroffenen nicht schlechter
wird das erfüllt dieser kompromiss daher
kann man das glaube ich schon sagen der
für uns entscheidende punkt als spd war
dass die leute nicht zum amt gehen und
dieses grundrente beantragen müssen weil
wir kennen das spiel schon überall dort
in unserem sozialstaat wohl jemand zum
amt gehen und sagen muss ich hätte gerne
unterstützung da scheuen viele menschen
diesen weg weil es ihnen peinlich ist
das kennen wir jetzt auch schon aus der
grundsicherung und das haben wir
ausgeschlossen die grundrente wird
automatisch gewährt das amt was die
rente auszahlte leicht dadurch dabei
sich mit dem
mit dem finanzamt ab und guckt wie sind
die einkommensverhältnisse und wenn alle
kriterien erfüllt sind dann kommt die
grundrente aufs konto ohne dass man
dafür einmal in irgendeiner abends stube
vorstellig werden musste und das ist gut
so richtig begeistert klicken sie aber
trotzdem nicht eigentlich müssten sie
doch sehr glücklich darüber sein und
viele andere sind es tatsächlich auch
weil sie das wirklich für gerechter und
zielgenauer halten wenn nur die geld
bekommen dies auch wirklich benötigen
das müsste doch eigentlich auch in ihrem
sinne sein
ja wir regieren mit der union zusammen
ich bin von natur aus immer skeptisch
und freue mich erst dann so richtig wenn
das wirklich im bundestag auch alles
beschlossen ist gestern gab es erstmal
nur eine einigung zwischen den
koalitionsparteien
jetzt muss das kabinett das erarbeiten
dann muss es durch den bundestag durch
und wenn das wirklich beschlossen ist
dann kann man sicher sein dass das auch
alles kommen wird aber natürlich bin ich
froh darüber dass diese einigung nicht
nur für zwei 300.000 rentnerinnen und
rentner gilt so wie die union das gerne
haben wollte sondern dass wir auch leute
mit einbeziehen die jetzt einfach eine
anerkennung ihrer leistung bekommen denn
wir stehen auf dem standpunkt dass es
eben nicht nur darum gehen kann wer
steht mit wirklich wirklich sehr wenig
geld im monat da sondern rente ist etwas
das bezieht sich darauf dass habe ich
eigentlich in der zeit meines lebens
geleistet unabhängig davon welche
anderen einnahmequellen ich vielleicht
doch auch noch habe deswegen geht es ja
auch nicht um so eine sozialleistung
nicht um eine sozialhilfe sondern es
geht um eine aufwertung der rente und
die muss dann natürlich auch für
diejenigen gelten die ein bisschen
besser im alter dastehen weil es ums
prinzip geht jetzt gibt es aber
natürlich auch kritik an der grundrente
einer ist das neue ungerechtigkeiten
geschaffen werden und da gibt es zum
beispiel einen kommentar hier bei
facebook da schreibt jimmy wer bekommt
denn überhaupt 35 jahre zusammen und
tatsächlich muss man sich das ja mal vor
augen führen wenn jetzt eine
teilzeitkraft 35 jahre arbeitet eine
vollzeitkraft aber vielleicht nur 33
jahre schafft dann obwohl sie bedürftig
ist würde die jetzt keine grundrente
bekommen das ist nicht wirklich gerecht
oder
es gibt immer ungerechtigkeiten das
beispiel mit den leuten die 33 oder 34
jahre gearbeitet haben und dann
möglicherweise leer ausgehen kamen
häufig in den letzten monaten und
deswegen bin ich froh dass das auch eine
rolle am wochenende bei den einigungen
gespielt hat sie finden jetzt in dem
schluss text der koalitionsparteien ein
bekenntnis dazu dass ein übergang
geschaffen werden soll dass wir also
nicht den harten schnitt machen wer 35
oder mehr jahre hat bekommt und wer 34
und elf monate hat bekommt es nicht
sondern dass es einen übergang geben
wird da hat man dann vielleicht etwas
geringere ansprüche aber man bekommt
trotzdem die grundrente weil solche
stichtagsregelung immer grund
ungerechtigkeiten beinhalten trotzdem
muss man sagen man kann wir können nicht
alle gesetze ablehnen die das leben
nicht für alle menschen am ende besser
machen also den leuten die jetzt
profitieren ist auch nicht geholfen wenn
wir die ganze grundrente aufhalten nur
weil nicht für jeden einzelnen rentner
die situation verbessert worden ist noch
mal trennte verbessert man nicht mit der
ein maßnahme wer in zukunft armutsrenten
verhindern will muss sich vor allem
fragen annehmen wie wie kommen wir vom
niedriglohnsektor weg brauchen wir einen
höheren mindestlohn beispielsweise wie
schaffen wir es dass nicht so viele
frauen teilzeit arbeiten wie das in der
vergangenheit der fall war und so weiter
dass die gründe die zu der situation
geführt haben mit der wir jetzt zu tun
haben alle fragen auf die wir vielleicht
gleich noch kommen wir haben jetzt über
die gerechtigkeit bezogen auf die
rentner gesprochen es gibt aber auch
stimmen die sagen die grundrente dies
ungerecht gegenüber der jüngeren
generation gegenüber denen die das ja
alles finanzieren müssen
vor allem weil das immer weniger werden
was das bedeutet zeigt jan frederik
fischer die deutsche gesellschaft ist im
steten wandel vor allem bei malta
doch wie genau sehen die zahlen
eigentlich aus
fakt ist die lebenserwartung ist in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten deutlich
gestiegen sagt sie vor kurzem bei 78,5
jahren bei den jungen waren es bei dem
mädchen 83,3 was bedeutet das konkret
1962 kam noch sechs arbeitnehmer für
einen rentner auf derzeit liegt das
verhältnis nur noch bei 2 arbeitnehmern
zu einem rentner und der blick in die
zukunft verheißt nichts gutes
trotz zuwanderung und gestiegener
geburtenrate laut einer schätzung des
statistischen bundesamts könnten im jahr
2020 rund 16,2 millionen menschen älter
als 60 jahre alt sein
2060 wären ist circa fünf millionen mehr
gleichzeitig gebe es weniger menschen
die zwischen 20 und 66 jahre alt und
potenziell erwerbstätig sind sollen bis
2020 noch 51,8 millionen sein
sind es 40 jahre später deutlich weniger
und die kritik die es hier deutlich auch
bei uns in den kommentaren zu lesen
die gibt es zum beispiel einen kommentar
bei youtube von schiri schreibt ja
glaubt weiterhin an die rente ihr
tagträumer der generationenvertrag ist
futsch die regierung sorgt sich jeden
cent aus unseren taschen also da ist
jemand sehr unzufrieden
herr kühn hat sie haben ja auch ein
statement abgegeben vergangene woche bei
maybrit illner da waren sie auch ein
bisschen sauer da haben sie gesagt dass
sie sich zitiere jetzt mal für eine
politische einstellung und nicht für
eine generation kämpfen und im zweifel
sogar ihren großeltern mehr wären jetzt
gibt es viele junge menschen die möchten
auch altersarmut bekämpfen die haben
aber gleichzeitig ängste ängste dass es
ihre eigene rente nicht reicht oder auch
dass diese finanzielle belastung schon
jetzt zu zeiten wo sie arbeiten zu hoch
ist können sie diese sorge nicht
verstehen
na klar kann ich die sorge verstehen
aber die rechnung ist eigentlich relativ
einfach wir jetzt nicht renten für
ältere menschen erhöht werden nicht
dafür sorgt dass die grundrente
eingeführt wird der hat das geld dann
nicht später für sich denn wir haben es
mit einem umlagesystem zu tun die renten
die jetzt ausbezahlt werden kommen aus
den beiträgen die jetzt bezahlt werden
das ist keine spardose das rentensystem
wo man geld reinwirft und dann wird das
sparschwein irgendwann geschlachtet
sondern es geht immer jetzt etwas rein
und im gleichen moment geht es auf der
anderen seite wieder raus
wer später eine sichere rente haben will
und die ist im moment nicht sicher da
gibt es überhaupt gar kein vertun der
muss darum kämpfen dass löhne besser
werden dass nicht mehr die hälfte der
jungen menschen in deutschland mit
befristeten arbeitsverhältnissen
einsteigen das wird zb auch was für solo
selbständige tun die unternehmen zu
arbeiten aber da gar nicht mehr richtig
angestellt sind und er tut sich und
seinen großeltern damit was gut ist denn
bessere löhne heißt ich krieg später
mehr rente
und es heißt aber auch ich zahle jetzt
mehr beiträge ein und sorge dafür dass
die lücke in der rentenversicherung
nicht so groß ist und letzte bemerkung
weil eine userin anscheinend gerade
gesagt hat die regierung kralle sich da
das geld wir reden hier über beiträge
das sind keine steuern die können nicht
für irgendetwas im haushalt verwendet
werden das kann man nicht für
autobahnbau oder sonst irgendetwas
nutzen was als beitrag eingezahlt wird
geht auch als rentenleistungen an
rentnerinnen und rentner aus anders ist
das nicht möglich wobei man jetzt sagen
muss die grundrente wird dann
steuerfinanziert also da sind sie eben
doch beiträge die also steuern die auch
für was anderes verwendet werden kann
das müssen wir schon sagen er könne die
sind ein paar kommentare aufgelaufen
die drehen sich darum wie man denn das
system eventuell ändern könnte ich lese
hier einfach mal fordern können wir auch
vielleicht darüber sprechen und zwar
wird hier auf twitter zum beispiel
geschrieben höhere löhne wären nicht nur
gerechtfertigt sondern bin auch der
altersarmut entgegenwirken
und dann gibt es hier mehrere kommentare
die gehen so in richtung
erwerbstätigenversicherung einmal bei
facebook von max der sagt wird daran
gearbeitet dass zukünftig alle in die
rentenkasse einzahlen also auch beamte
politiker und selbstständige und ganz
ähnlichen kommentar den gibt es hier
eigentlich auch bei youtube
weil momentan ist das system ja eben
noch an dass also die frage wird daran
gearbeitet und gleichzeitig sehen wir
aber rente ab 63
mütter rente grundrente da kann schon
der eindruck entstehen bei der jüngeren
generation daran wird eben mehr
gearbeitet es wird mehr im blick auf die
älteren gelegt als jetzt vielleicht
daran ein system zu schaffen was dann
auch für die jüngeren gut ist gut wenn
wir entscheidungen bei der rente treffen
dann sind die immer im moment erstmal
für die ältere generation weil das ist
die die moment rente bekommt aber was
wir heute beschließen gilt ja auch für
die die in 10 20 oder 30 jahren
in rente gehen also heute rentenpolitik
zu machen heißt eigentlich vor allem
sich um die nächsten generationen zu
kümmern
denn wer heute in rente ist der weiße in
aller regel wasser bekommt ich finde den
vorschlag mit der
erwerbstätigenversicherung oder um es
auf deutsch zu sagen eine
rentenversicherungen die alle leute in
deutschland einzahlen
das finde ich richtig das wollen wir
auch gerne als spd also nicht nur wie
bisher sondern auch mit selbständigen
auch mit beamten auch mit politikerinnen
und politikern die da einzahlen dass es
aber mit unserem koalitionspartner nicht
zu machen dafür brauchen wir andere
politische mehrheiten in deutschland
aber das wäre eine sehr gute möglichkeit
genau so wie ich habe es ja schon
erwähnt wie auch die höheren löhne eine
wichtige stellschraube dafür sind und
noch mal kurz zum thema steuern sie
haben völlig recht es werden auch
steuermittel verwendet das war aber
schon immer in der rente so die rente
hat sich noch nie auch nicht vor 50
jahren alleine aus den beiträgen
finanziert sondern der staat hat immer
steuermittel dazu gegeben weil wir da
auch in der rente leistung mit bezahlen
wie kindererziehung oder ähnliches das
wird mit angerechnet die trägt die
gesamte gesellschaft mit deswegen gibt
die auch über steuern was rein das ist
kein bruch mit der solidarität und mit
der generationengerechtigkeit
nichtsdestotrotz muss man eben
festhalten es gibt viele junge die da
eben kein vertrauen mehr ins system
haben so wie sie das jetzt gerade im
vorderen teil geschildert haben klingt
das so als wenn viel getan werden würde
und dass nun nicht ankommt bei der
jungen generation finden sie es wird
genug gemacht
nein das finde ich nicht
wir haben um das auch deutlich zu sagen
wir haben im moment noch fünf jahre bis
zum jahr 2025 sicherheit was die
gesetzliche rente angeht bis 2025 wissen
diejenigen die dann in rente gegangen
sein werden dass sie 48 prozent im
schnitt von ihrem letzten lohn bekommen
werden was danach mit der rente passiert
ist unsicher weil wir im moment eine
regierung haben aus parteien die sich
nicht einig sind
in dieser frage die union möchte gerne
auch die fdp dass wir mehr private
vorsorge machen dass die leute sich
selber kümmern
wir wollen gern die gesetzliche rente
stärken ist es einfach ein streitpunkt
und es gibt keine klaren mehrheiten
was wir aber tun um das also ich will
jetzt hier kein großes anderes thema
aufmachen aber wir machen ja
gleichzeitig an anderer stelle auch
durchaus politik für jüngere menschen
werden zum beispiel mindestlohn
auszubildende vor zwei wochen gerade im
deutschen bundestag beschlossen oder die
bafög leistung verbessert also nur weil
jetzt im moment gerade über rente
geredet wird und da gestern was
beschlossen wurde zu dem thema heißt das
ja nicht dass sich nur noch um alte
menschen in der gesellschaft gekümmert
wird und wie gesagt ich habe auch ein
interesse daran als enkel dass auch
meine großeltern für ihre lebensleistung
des gerichtes bekommen und ich finde
zumindest bei mir in der familie hat der
generationenvertrag funktioniert ich
habe von denen liebe zuwendungen
wertevermittlung bekommen die haben viel
in mich investiert und ich habe nicht
das gefühl dass die auf die meine kosten
oder die unserer generation tatsächlich
jetzt leben und so werden das sicherlich
auch viele andere enkel sehen die uns
wahrscheinlich auch gerade zu schauen
jetzt sind sie schon ein bisschen
persönlicher geworden
zum ende vielleicht darf ich noch diese
persönlichere frage stellen sie selber
verlassen sie sich auf die gesetzliche
rente oder sorgen sie auch noch privat
vor ja ich finde es wichtig dass
politikerinnen und politiker zudem
tatsächlich auch stehen was sie sagen
und wenn ich nun mal das tue ich dafür
eintreten dass wir die gesetzliche rente
stark machen sollen dann wäre es total
komisch wenn ich gleichzeitig sagen
würde eigentlich glaube ich gar nicht
mehr dran und kümmere mich privat um
alles ich zahle in die gesetzliche rente
ein und kämpfe politisch dafür dass das
dann im alter ausreichen wird ich habe
keine private altersvorsorge daneben und
findet dass auch komisch in einer jungen
generation wo das erste mal seit langem
im schnitt schlechter verdient wird als
in unserer elterngeneration diesen
jungen leuten zuzurufen da liegt doch
noch was bei seite für die private
vorsorge
das können sich viele nicht leisten
genauso betriebliche vorsorge ich freue
mich über jeden deren betrieb hat der
ihm noch ein bisschen geld beiseite legt
für die altersvorsorge aber für die
allermeisten ist das heute nicht
realität und deswegen bitte keine
versteck spielchen und keine ausreden
aus der politik sondern unser job ist
die gesetzliche rente auch für die
nächste generation funktionsfähig zu
machen und wer das hinten wir
hinterfragt oder nicht deutlich sagt der
spiel tatsächlich mit den
zukunftsperspektiven derer die heute
jung sind
das hat kevin kühnert der
bundesvorsitzende der jusos
herr kühne hat wahrscheinlich jetzt
gerade einen schlussplädoyer da würden
viele großeltern ihren enkel eventuellen
anderen ratschlag geben und ich bedanke
mich ganz herzlich dass sie sich die
zeit genommen
danke schön und ich bedanke mich
natürlich auch ganz herzlich bei euch
für die vielen fragen die hier
aufgelaufen sind die nächsten live
stream gibt es hier am donnerstag um
20.30 dann ist daniel wieder für euch da
und ich hoffe ihr seid dann auch wieder
dabei das wird uns sehr freuen
[Musik]
und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat dann interessiert euch
vielleicht auch dieser hier
da haben wir über hartz4 sanktionen
gesprochen oder der hier
da ging es darum wie man es auch als
arbeiter kind an die uni schafft oder
ihr klickt einfach da und lassen aber
das wird uns sehr freuen
[Musik]